WELCOME BACK.
IF THE ECONOMY IS A MURKY SOUS
VIDE BAKED TURKEY BUT WITH THE
PILGRIMS OF FIND ABSURD TO EAT
PLACE FOR A RECENT SURVEY FOUND
THAT 64 PERCENT OF PEOPLE THAT
64 AT A HUNDRED SAY THEY MIGHT
OPT FOR PAM PLANT -BASED TURKEY
DUE TO THE RISING PRICE OF MEAT.
ALSO THERE INSANE LUST FOR
KILLING PLANTS.
THE ONLY REASON VEGETARIANS EAT
PLANTS IS BECAUSE PLANTS IT
CAN'T RUN AWAY AND VEGETARIANS
ARE TOO LAZY T STUFF WITH LEGS.
THIS YEAR THE AVERAGE TURKEY
WILL COST US 17 PERCENT MORE
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR.
I SHOULD'VE BOUGHT THIS YEAR'S
TURKEY LAST YEAR.
FOR NEXT YEAR WHEN I FIX MY TIM
MACHINE.
A'S AMERICA THE STREETS ARE
PAVED WITH TOFU WITH EMPHASIS O
F YOU WHILE YOU'RE GIVING THANK
TO ROUND THE DINNER TABLE NEXT
WEEK REMEMBER THAT THE CHILD BY
THE GANGS OF UNEATEN AND GREAT
TURKEYS ROAMING THE STREETS WHE
IN CRANBERRY SAUCE AS
SCHOOLCHILDREN.
>> CAP DO YOU HAVE PLANS FOR
THANKSGIVING IS ANYBODY THERE
GOING TO BE EATING A PLANT PLAN
ALTERNATIVE?
>> PROBABLY NOT NEITHER EDDIE'S
PEOPLE THE SURVEY SAID TO ADDED
THREE PEOPLE ARE CONSIDERING IT
DOES NOT MEAN THEY'RE GOING TO
DO IT.
YOU DON'T DO EVERYTHING YOU YOU
CONSIDER AT THAT'S HOW YOU GO T
JAIL BE BACK I WORRY WHAT WILL
BECOME OF THE TARGAC AND WHICH
ACTUALLY KILLS THREE BIRDS WITH
ONE STONE.
>> THAT'S TRUE AND NO ONE THAT
BEFORE THE TARGAC IN EVERY
REALLY GET POPULAR?
IT IS AT MY HOUSE IT'S A CHICKE
AND A DUCK IN A TURKEY.
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
CONDITION PEOPLE TO ONE TO
WELCOME THE PLANT ALTERNATIVE.
I WAS ON A PLANE RECENTLY THEY
OFFERED A MEAL AND SAID OKAY YO
CAN HAVE THE CHICKEN OR THE
BEYOND BECAUSE UNLIKE JUST MADE
THE DECISION FORMAT HAVE TO DO
THE CHICKEN BECAUSE OF MY EATIN
THE PLANT MEATBALLS BUT THEY
WANT YOU TO THINK IT'S THE WAY
IT'S GOING TO BE.
I THINK IT'S PART OF THE
RESPONSE OF PEOPLE FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE TO SAY OF COURSE IF
IT'S HIGH-END THAT I WOULD DO
THE PLANT I DON'T REALLY WANT A
PLANT TURKEY.
>> WILL NOT BE FIGHTING A PETE
WAS SECRETLY A VEGETARIAN?
HAD NOT EVEN A VEGETABLE IN
THREE WEEKS UP YOUR YARD.
>> WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT THIS
IS KIND OF IT--PLAYFUL ASSUME
PLANTS DON'T HAVE FEELINGS BUT
THEY DO HAVE A CONSCIOUSNESS OF
THEIR SALES MOVE IN A DIRECTION.
>> I INTO TO MY PLANTS I TO THE
AND THEY FEED THEM THEIR
BEAUTIFUL.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK.
>> I DON'T KNOW I JUST SAYING.
>> I WANT TO FELL MOTHER.
>> I WANT TO BE ONE OF HER
PLANTS.
>> I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU HAVE YO
EVER HAD THE PLANT PLANT -BASED
FOOD?
I HAD IT ONCE I THOUGHT I'D KIL
MYSELF.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
IT'S AWFUL.
JUST EAT THE MEAT THEY DON'T
WANT YOU TO EAT THE MEAT THEY
ARE EATING THE TURKEY THEY JUST
DON'T WANT YOU TO.
>> I'M AGREEING WITH YOU.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT A TURKEYS
HAD BRAINS THAT THEY'D WANT AS
TO EAT THEM AND ADD THEIR
MISERABLE LIVES THERE
UNATTRACTIVE BEASTS THEY'RE VER
WATERY TO BE EVER BEEN CHASED B
A TURKEY?
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN CHASED BY
ANYTHING.
>> YOU ARE TOP OF THE FOODCHAIN
HERE'S THE DEAL TURKEYS MIGHT
COST MORE BUT THE LITTLE PLANT
-BASED TURKEY COST A LOT AND NO
TO MENTION IT SCORCHED-EARTH TO
GROW THE LITTLE PLANTS THAT THE
KILL EVERYTHING CLOSE TO THE
GROUND IT TO GLOAT GROW IT.
IT'S NOT CUTE IT LIKE A BABY CO
BUT KILLING EVERY COBRA SNAKE
CRICKET EVERY LITTLE SMALL BODY
ANYTHING THAT LIVES IN OR UNDER
THE GROUND IT TO GREG LITTLE
PLANTS AND ALL THE MONEY IT
COSTS AND OTHER SUBSIDIES AS A
TURKEY MIGHT BE 70 PERCENT BUT
WOULD YOU BOTHER THAT SAWDUST A
THE LIKE A BIRD WHO MOLDS IT TO
MAKE IT LOOK LIKE A DEAD BODY?
IF YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE PLANT
-BASED SOMETHING MAKE IT LIKE A
[ BLEEP ]
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO MIMIC IT?
IF THAT'S SO GREAT, IF IT'S SO
WONDERFUL, WHY DOES IT TASTE
LIKE THE LORD BLESSED IT WHY NO
MAKE IT WHAT IT REALLY IS A PIL
OF [ BLEEP ]
WHY MAKE IT LOOK LIKE THIS DEAD
THING YOU'RE TRYING TO SAVE.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
>> IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GO
OUT AND HUNTED AND BRING IT
BECAUSE TURKEYS ARE TOP THEY'RE
NOT EASY TO SHOOT DOWN.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO ALL THAT
THAT MIGHT MAKE IT LOOK LIKE TH
BODY OF THE THING YOU'RE
SUPPOSEDLY TRYING TO SAY?
THAT'S AMAZING I LIKE THAT YOU
BUY A BURGER IT'S NOT SHAPED
LIKE A COW.
BUT IF YOU BUY A VEGGIE BURGER
IS SHAPED LIKE A COW BURGER
BECAUSE IF YOU SAW WHAT IT
REALLY LOOKED LIKE, YOU WOULD
NOT EAT